my goal is i feel like it's like a  divine purpose to empower people we've  never had a government which looks to  empower people but that is the only way  because no one is coming to save you and  even when they give you that stimulus  check to save you you put it into some  dumb nft and then it crashes you put it  into shiba inu and then it crashes  because you have zero financial literacy  because nobody has educated you they've  empowered you to become dependent and  just feed their the rubbish feed the  rubbish that comes through the media  like oh inflation's going to be great  because you know why higher wages  exactly well that's not true